question alors comme ça l'homme
descendait du singe
c'est pas si simple
car que l'homme descend du singe n'est
pas tout à fait exact puisque cette
expression place clairement l'espèce
humaine à part des autres singes or si
l'homme descend du singe
alors il appartient à la famille des
sages dire le contraire serait comme
dire que vous êtes un descendant de
votre grand mère mais que vous ne faites
pas partie de la même famille ce serait
grotesque
donc nous ne descendrons pas du singe
nous sommes des singes mais au fait
quand on part singes au juste
ben oui il existe plusieurs espèces de
singes il y a les chimpanzés bien sûr
auquel on pense tout de suite mais il ya
aussi les gorilles et les orangs-outans
les mandrills les babouins
les macaques les singes hurleurs lewis
ça va ça va on a compris on a compris
donc dire que l'homme descend du singe
ces régimes et la diversité des prix
mais tout seul s'impose finalement la
question reste entière
qu'est ce que les singes mettre l'homme
à part des sages c'est dire qu'ils ne
possèdent pas d'ancêtres communs avec
les autres sachent
or cela il faut puisque le chimpanzé par
exemple est génétiquement plus proche de
nous que de n'importe quel autre singe
en effet entre 95 et 99 % de son code
génétique c'est-à-dire de son code-barre
d'adé n est identique au nôtre donc
finalement nous descendrons des singes
comme les chimpanzés les gorilles et les
orangs-outans descendent aussi des
singes nous avons tous un ancêtre commun
qui était déjà lui même un sage et le
mot sage rassemble tous les descendants
de cet ancêtre commun nous y compris
ainsi soit lomitas singes sol mou singes
ne veut plus rien dire